So, what happens prior to 1096, prior to
the first Crusade? And because once I
was in school, let's say third, fourth,
fifth grade, I was told though although
Lithuania is a very Christian country,
Catholic country, but I was told that
the the Crusades were horrible incident
incidents innocent people were killed,
slaughtered, raped, and etc.
Right. You're the country you come from
and Estonia and those sort of Baltic
regions don't like the Crusades because
they were Christianized
in parts of those Crusades. Including at
the hands of the Teutonic Knights,
a military order, a Catholic military
order. So, the original Crusades had
nothing to do with that. It was against
Islam and the very first Crusade which
was called in 1095 was completely
against Muslims because they were
persecuting and horrifically killing
Christians and destroying churches. And
going back now to Constantine and the
Holy Sepulchre in Jerusalem, which was a
pilgrimage site since the time before
Constantine, but especially after
Constantine, and it continued being a
pilgrimage site even after the Muslim
conquest of the Holy Land around 637.
But and and Christians would suffer and
they had to pay taxes and sometimes they
would be attacked and killed by Muslims,
but they still would go as a sacrifice
because holy sites were very important
back in those days. So, that goes on
I'm just going a little before the first
Crusade and then by the time of you know
around 900 or 1000 the Turks start
rising and they become a very dominant
force in the Islamic world and they're
Muslims. They were originally imported
as slave soldiers by the caliphates,
especially the Abbasid caliphate at the
time, and they would bring these Turkic
warriors and convert them to Islam and
they became the greatest warriors. And
then before you know it they actually
became the standard bearers of Jihad and
the Arabs time wanes and really the
caliphate is a public is a puppet
figure, the Abbasid caliphate which the
Turks keep, but they're in charge,
they're in power. And under them the
first dynasty really is well not the
first but the the more dominant one is
the Seljuk Turks.
And they start attacking Asia Minor in
around the middle of the 11th century,
1050, and very horrific the bloodshed is
just mind-boggling as it's recorded in
the sources. Especially Armenians
because Armenians are a large nation at
this time in Asia Minor, but also as
they go later further in against Greeks
and so forth. And the records you know
Matthew of Edessa is a chronicler who's
a near contemporary, he talks about tens
of thousands of Christians being
massacred, even more enslaved. Just
because they refused to convert? Yeah,
by the Turks.
And churches ritually desecrated and
destroyed in one city, Ani, which was
the capital at the time of Armenia. It
was known as the city of a thousand and
one churches, they were all burned and
destroyed. All the
a large crucifix was sent to Baghdad as
a trophy of war, again underscoring the
ideological aspect to this.
And also the pilgrims who were going to
the Holy Land to see the Holy Sepulchre
were being attacked in very vile ways.
One of the more famous and horrific
instances was a large German pilgrimage
which was in 1064 or 1065 and they talk
about how they attacked and killed
everyone and they took a nun and
gang-raped her until she died in front
of everyone. And the eyewitness says and
the Turks did this often to pilgrims.
And that's what gave rise to the first
Crusade in 1095.
>> Just to prove the horror? Just the sheer
horror and attacks on Christians. And so
Pope Urban the Second in 1095, in part
responding to the Roman Emperor Alexius
who was now under because all these were
formerly Eastern Roman Byzantine
territories. So, he asked for aid from
the West. And he described what was
happening. And that's exactly what Pope
Urban and all the other you know
preachers of the first Crusade were
talking about which is what was
happening to Christians, what was
happening to the Holy Land, what was
happening to pilgrims. And that was the
the rise of the first Crusade, it was a
noble venture, it was altruistic, it was
about actually righting wrongs. They
actually would quote the verse that you
know no greater love does a man have
than to lay down his life for his fellow
man. And that's what they were doing.
And all and also in the context of you
know loving God and loving your fellow
man. So, loving your fellow man was
going on a Crusade to help Eastern
Christians. Loving God was going to go
and liberate the Holy Land. Jerusalem.
Because they were mocking. So, in 1009,
which is even way before 1095,
one caliph the Holy Sepulchre, the large
massive complex that Constantine built
was just he destroyed it. He completely
destroyed it, plundered it, and he
destroyed 30,000 other churches
according to Muslim sources. Most
Western historians don't say this, they
say
>> 30,000? 30,000 and most Western
historians will put the number 300 or
3000 and they'll say oh that's a scribal
error, the Muslims are wrong. But it's a
Muslim, it's Al-Maqrizi, it's an
Egyptian historian. So, they were not
boast just boasting. No. They were
telling the truth. Yeah. And it's a
reflection of how Christian that region
was because before the Islamic conquest
even in 1009, that's only 400 years
later, it was still a very very heavily
Christian region,
Egypt and Greater Syria. So, 30,000
churches and the Holy Sepulchre
destroyed.
So, all of that and and the Christians
of Europe remembered that. So, that's
what gave rise and led to the first
Crusade. What was the draft like in the
first Crusade?
>> Yeah, who was those people?
>> There was no draft. This was it was
unbridled enthusiasm and it was women
and children, peasants. You couldn't
stop them. They were so and it's it's
actually considered one of today's great
mysteries because there were calls to
other Crusades before that including
when that caliph destroyed the Sepulchre
and the 30,000 churches, that too
provoked a lot of Christians in the
West, but nothing came of it. But for
some reason when when Pope Urban called
for this one, it just it's known in
history as one of the most massive
campaigns where it was hundreds of
thousands of just peasants took off to
the Holy Land. It was a pilgrimage, it
was the Crusades were actually
pilgrimages. So, Christians wanted to do
and should do pilgrimage to the Holy
Land and the Crusade was seen as an
armed pilgrimage. So, you're doing two
things, you're going to go
and you're going to fight the pagans and
help Christians and liberate the Holy
Land and you're going to do the
pilgrimage which you should do. The
people were really driven
just by the actual events themselves.
So, we can say yeah, there was a
theological component that motivated
them, there's no doubt about that. But
at the same time it was really trying to
redress all these wrongs that I just
described because that comes out in the
sources, that's what really
they preached, Urban, Peter the Hermit,
and all these other preachers and that's
what really drove the people to go on
the Crusade.